the festive mood of football fans on
occasion devolves into
tear gas pepper spray and arrests
as Qatar prepares to host an estimated 1
million fans but the first World Cup in
the Middle East security is Paramount
the country's size its first time
hosting a Mega Sports event and the
compact nature of eight stadiums
presents specific challenges
but the CEO of the International Center
for sports security says Qatar has been
preparing for more than a decade and has
a track record of Hosting smaller
tournaments such as the Asian cup I
don't think we can state that the World
Cup will happen in a country which is
unprepared in managing let's say
exceptional situations
the successful element of the strength
of Qatar is that the the World Cup in
Qatar is a part of a of a bigger let's
say Vision Qatar has been staging
simulations and conducting training
exercises for security forces it's also
partnering with countries including
Britain Spain and turkey to provide
assistance ranging from crowd control to
counter-terrorism measures turkey is
sending a team of more than 2 200 people
including police officers and doctors
the World Cup is a major event on its
own but having it for the first time in
Qatar and in a Muslim country is a
responsibility on top of that our
president told us helping Carter is like
hosting your brother's wedding this is
how excited we are and how much we want
to help a number of global safety
indexes rank Qatar at the top last year
200 000 fans attended the Arab FIFA cup
it's considered a successful stress test
for Qatar 2022.
[Applause]
and there's hope that perhaps this
November's World Cup will someday be a
kind of dry run for hosting the Olympics
Natasha good name Al Jazeera Doha